when you hear deborah birx dr. Burks say
it's just devastating ly worrisome to
see people outside breaking the
guidelines that we all have agreed upon
have kept us safe and continue to what
do you think Harris I think there's a
couple of things first of all it depends
on the state and she was talking about
Michigan where there's been 45 thousand
cases and a recent surge not clear that
they're flattening the curve you know
Florida is about 35,000 cases but
Florida the question isn't in my mind in
my opinion whether the beaches should be
open but how long you keep them open
when there are no public bathrooms is it
possible to keep social distancing on
the beaches I think it might be I think
it might be you're seeing people walking
along the sidewalks anyway the real
question is region by region how many
cases have you flattened the curve and
can you get people outside in a way
because you and I have talked a lot
about mental health issues and boy a
couple of hours on the beach if you can
go Bay the social distancing is great
for mental health in a state like
Florida you know you you talk about
bathroom facilities hand-washing is such
a huge part of all this no matter how
much hand sanitizer you have at the
beach it mixes with sand and I got to
imagine you got kind of a mess on your
hand you need to go and wash them off
but the length of time is something that
that probably legally could be talked
about too I mean you might want to add
that into your guidelines Emily I'm
gonna ask you with your legal background
are any of these leaders on shaky ground
if the guidelines really are too wide
notwithstanding what the Attorney
General has said that they need to take
another look at them and that they may
be overstepping but just common sense
wise you know you hear dr. Siegel
talking about bathroom facilities at the
beach right the issue becomes when
constitutional rights and liberties are
being infringed and that's really when
there's a very high bar for these
governors and these state leaders to
cross if they're actually going to pass
judicial muster and we talked about this
before that the test is whether whether
it's the least restrictive means of
accomplishing a legitimate goal so
a plaintiff can argue look here's a way
to accomplish this legitimate public
health goal without trampling on my
constitutional right then that's when
they're on shaky ground and I have to
say dr. Siegel touched on that regional
nature I'm sitting here in Washington
and I'm from California
my governor just extended the
stay-at-home order through the end of
this month but he announced a four phase
plan each phase last seen about three
weeks and he has refused to give
specific data that's led him to this
conclusion because he says look I'm
waiting for it to be favorable but the
difference is that here he's allowed any
County that does meet certain criteria
to basically apply to be exempt and he
says there are ten counties here but
essentially can get back to work sooner
but in California that's 58 counties 15
of which have seen zero deaths and yet
governor Gavin Newsom continues to apply
sort of that one side under Stephan this
is why it's such an issue